[Music]
discount Looney Toons
goddamn those are some mirror shine
floors goddamn Roger is definitely
looking up this woman's skirt right now
quit bars function as sling shots in a
cartoon world but as we find out later
this is being filmed by a real world
crew so how do they make that happen
does anybody draw this or do cartoon
physics just happen naturally are you
saying we shouldn't apply logic to this
movie you've come to the wrong place a
responsible oven company sells a product
with a setting of volcano heat
convenient pile of dishes allow baby
Herman to crawl across the sink in what
is an otherwise spotless kitchen this
oven has a setting that when reached
shoots the cooked food out into the
kitchen like a missile that's handy is
this the largest residential kitchen in
recorded history bar of soap has enough
force to slam into the baby and nudge
him close enough to grab this pendulum
the kitchen is set up in such a way that
no one would be able to reach these
comically stacked pots and pans without
a ladder and as Rogers run around the
kitchen proves there is more than enough
cabinet space to put these in without
creating a safety hazard also chili
sauce found its way amongst all these
pots pans and cheese graters because
whoever does the cooking in this house
is the dumbest person alive on stored
unrefrigerated and probably moldy bread
despite general odds none of these
knives hit Roger this vacuum cleaner
wasn't here before
yeah no Rogers head did not impact and
break the bottom of the fridge like this
[Music]
lines this director is addicted cartoon
birds how's Roger responsible for the
bird showing up do you mean this is like
crying on cue you have an assortment of
I just got banged in the head animations
in your head the set is actually
impossible given the full 360 shots at
the kitchen we saw just a few moments
earlier during the scene when the camera
was supposedly filming 23 times how does
Roger screw up the birds vs. stars thing
that many times and that was the first
time the director pointed out the stars
thing and the script after 23 times and
what does it matter
two's that's racist also Mad Men levels
of casual liquor mr. maroon mr. valiant
soon to be joined no doubt by mr. brave
who killed mr. innocent in the kitchen
with mr. Nobles wrench the guy carrying
this film is scratching the fuck out of
it by running into another room and
letting it drag on the editing machine
and a floor I want you to follower give
me a couple of nice juicy pictures wrap
it up which movie that is essentially
for kids that's a pee I hired to take
photos of Jessica Rabbit having
sex with another man subplot by the way
I can say without a hesitation that the
film these guys are carrying will not
get untangled for another two hours at
least
is this a point one-up what the fucker
and oh my god I forgot my medication
Fantasia broome extras have been
relegated to a life of sweeping film
studio Lots while holding the other
broom broom section too many seconds of
him gaping at toon behavior that
shouldn't really surprise him at all but
is mostly here for the viewing audience
to adapt to throwing your bills in the
trash is a terrible financial strategy
to kill this brother how is this not
already common knowledge how and why are
there tumbleweeds in a downtown big city
alley nice monkey suit that's racist
Donald Duck vs. Daffy Duck on piano is
clearly the most logical use of both of
these characters clearly an octopus
bartender seems like a great idea until
you see him popping around behind the
bar like this and you realize you're
screwed as a customer this thing's gone
the stain is not gone but it helpfully
waits to disappear when Eddie looks down
at it ruby has time for a Betty Boop
reference the teens and kids didn't even
understand when this movie came out
but regardless gamma lights anyone yeah
but Mickey Mouse started out black and
white too didn't he and he's color now
is that because of an operation
why did Betty Boop get left out of the
colorization also this makes me wonder
if there are multiple differently drawn
Bugs Bunny and Mickey Mouse characters
running around in toontown
did they have stolen identity conflicts
the physical proportions of this cartoon
female are so exaggerated I'm not sure I
can get anything more than a cartoon
boner over it also the movie says it's
okay to be attracted to cartoons and I'm
okay with that and I am NOT okay with
that
also unrelated I'm wondering if humans
can have sex with toons and what would
that be like are your genitals covered
in paint afterwards
[Music]
one hour 45-minute movie might not be so
long if it didn't let scenes like this
stretch on into eternity here we are a
minute later she's still King singing we
get it she can sing and she's a cartoon
and she's hot
got it we had it two minutes ago but
thanks for the bull super giant keyhole
you can eavesdrop through is convenient
but I really don't think there's a key
in the world that fits this thing and
works
that's way racist we find out later that
Jessica is staging this pattycake
session with AD me so that Eddie will
take pictures of it but it required him
being thrown out first to get a good
look if he didn't get thrown out these
pictures would have been 75% keyhole and
perhaps 0% pattycake and his camera
wasn't nearly fast enough and didn't
merely take enough pictures for this
flip book animation joke this movie will
now use literal pattycake as a sex
metaphor because with the am i watching
hey Bob Hoskins lay down on a desk and
act like a cartoon rabbit is attacking
you okay necklace enough hurting physics
somehow translate their nonsense to
real-world objects so Roger Rabbit speed
bolted out the window so fast he lifts
his impression in the glass and the
blinds but he only went as far as the
main Acme building two blocks away
before melting down into a blubbering
mess thankfully the contents of this
desk are arranged in an expositionally
friendly way this asshole not only left
a bunch of newspaper trimmings hanging
around for expositional purposes he even
left the scissors which suggests he's
cutting newspaper trimmings to this day
which is ludicrous his brother died ages
ago also the fact that goofy was ever
brought up on spy charges goofy of all
people cop school does not include a
rigorous class for checking a dead guy's
hand a coarse corpse course of course
this guy's name is judge doom is he
related to dr. doom when the people in
this movie find out he's the bad guy do
you think they might wonder how they
missed all the signs the black outfit
the spectacles the cane the name and the
inherent evil these assholes working for
the man in black crushed their way into
a crime scene with no repercussions
whatsoever hey shoo what were you doing
nuzzling him earlier if he was such a
danger a newbie tries to make me feel
bad about the murder of a shoe yeah what
the movie is suddenly telling me is that
despite that flaw this three-year-old
cartoon is currently getting it on with
a grown human female also this movie
filled with sex innuendo and violence is
PG how do Robert Zemeckis and Steven
Spielberg convince the MPA in trouble
you might want to help get him out Eddie
who really needs the money turns down a
job and Trump's a baby down a hallway
just because of a perceived insult that
in the grand scheme of things isn't that
insulting Acme casually walked around
with his last will and testament in his
pocket and in plain view of anyone who
cared to notice
I got no keys for these cuffs private
detective keeps a set of handcuffs in
his closet he has no keys for and they
said David Carradine had closet based
fetishes the best way these weasel tune
cops can think of to get through this
ancient locked door is to use a machine
gun instead of you know breaking the
glass and turning the interior handle
weasel clearly sees Roger but doesn't
it's the Schrodinger's cat of seeing
thing and now we know where Lion King
got its hyenas so is the strongest
object in the toon universe
I guess Roger is invisible to everyone
because Eddie is trying really hard to
keep him hidden and everyone's I forgive
that also Roger who's super wants to
live keeps doing like this we've been
given explicit information that only the
judge doom acid kills toons so why do
toons even worry about death and let's
confront it with a giant vat of sludge
that clearly changed Jack Napier into
the Joker for reasons I will never
understand valiant begins trying to saw
through the wrist part of the handcuffs
directly into his own flesh as opposed
to sawing into the much smaller metal
chain between the cuffs um he's barely
moving and you're sawing your own cuff
think so
Roger casually slides out of the cuffs
now that they're safe and what the what
an asshole
not only is he using it all to clean his
ears he's cleaning both at the same time
shoving this all straight through his
brain you might could get away with this
in a cartoon but in a movie that is only
half cartoon no way dude cartoons are
ridiculously slow when they appear
behind opaque glass parently you aren't
drawn at all you just came to life and
put thousands of animators out of work
are these two really going out we heard
and saw things about the past but they
seems like ex-lovers she's jealous now
[Applause]
how did these assholes know to be here
aren't they supposed to be super
incompetent Roger has literally no clue
what the word fugitive means why are you
so gung-ho about making people laugh now
but earlier you were desperate to stay
hidden in Eddie's apartment sleeping in
his height Abed is this movie saying
that this guy seemed the purest surprise
winning play Harvey or the movie that
came out three years later judging by
the knowing reaction I'm guessing movie
which is impossible
that would mean your weasel gang too
though right
also the fact that this shave and a
haircut involuntary responsible is a
thing even in toontown this is some
stupid-ass great dooms about to put
Roger in the dip but if Jessica truly
was drawn as she said couldn't someone
just draw a Roger again why would the
judge agree to let Roger have a last
drink mere inches from his decimation
well why not well why not it's taking
judge doom at his weasels so long to
leave the bar I can't either x mark in a
vehicle of x mark Ananas from x mark and
a bill why does a cartoon cab in los
angeles care about the Brooklyn Dodgers
Robert Zemeckis can't help but refer to
the movie he made three years previously
that obviously nobody saw I don't know
maybe tell him a bridge is up ahead
rather than making them figure it out
Eddie takes a highly wounded Roger to
the movies in a theater that is
jam-packed downstairs but nobody
bothered to go to the balcony for some
reason what's wrong with you you went to
a movie theater to hide who does that
other than Lee Harvey Oswald wait a
minute
Lee Harvey Oswald Harvey the rabbit
coincidence drop the pianos from 15
stories was it a cartoon piano or a real
piano I'll tell you why I think this
matters if cartoon objects function
basically the way regular objects do
this would solve nearly all the world's
problems you could just draw the things
you need why are there problems in this
world I did find out who that guy was
but something tells me that story and
this story are connected somehow
luli news reel contains information
extremely vital to the plot movie studio
at the center of a major conspiracy has
zero security eddie trust roger to cover
his back someone got paid to write that
line a story of greed sex and murder
or if your Zemeckis in spielberg you can
keep anything you want and still have a
PG rating who is able to shoot this
accurately through a window without even
being seen movie accidentally inspires
Back to the Future to tunnel one year
later why would the gun be cartoon but
in a real box also despite cartoon
things working in the real world
apparently regular guns don't work in
toontown only toon guns eddie quits
drinking and then decides i also have to
waste one of my bullets shooting the
bottle out of the air I thought I was in
toontown this whole movie but apparently
I was not mind blown I'm not sure if
Eddie's actually here probably because
his actual presence in the toon world
looks fake --is-- is basically no
distinction but
the real world in the cartoon world
anymore after both worlds contain
oversized keyhole scenes Tweety is a
Sylvester - valiant so movie is saying
he'd be dead if not for the accidental
walk in on the bizarro Jessica Rabbit
earlier because if so then movie I heard
footsteps must be related to my case as
it turns out this magic gun Eddie
remembered to bring and was such a big
deal earlier was totally worthless this
cat must work for the ex machina taxi
service how the everliving did he know
they'd be coming through this tunnel
right at this moment how long has he
been standing here waiting for them like
hours all bad guys are rapists and the
fact that I'm saying that in a PG movie
kind of creeps me to some puns are funny
I don't know why he announced where he
was going either but ain't that lucky by
any chance
dude like we traded companies ever have
just a sole stockholder is that even
possible but it is remember you guys
can't die except for the doom dip so why
are you scared of a gun literal irony
which in this case isn't funny literally
or figuratively this is why you don't
hire weasels as your henchmen they turn
on you at the first sign of hilarity why
does doom think that Eddie has some
major emotional tie to Roger and Jessica
that his devastation would be that fun
to watch the answer is he doesn't
meaning doom is only doing it so the
heroes can be saved also this guy walks
off before seeing any of his enemies
killed like a Batman TV show villainy is
allowed to do this ya better stop him
from finishing that lyric or else this
movie can't be for kids anymore he's
dying weasels sure managed to ex machina
their stuff to still be dangerous to our
heroes even after their deaths
this really is an episode of the old
Batman TV show I get the sense Roger and
Jessica could have been dipped in the
dip rather than spray but that's what I
get when I look for logic and half
cartoons why did this asshole even leave
in the first place CB was that unsure
his henchmen could finish the job did he
walk out then like hide for five minutes
cuz even doing all this time why was the
singing sword tune boy ever put into
production who are the ad wizards that
came up with this cartoon magnet effects
real-world metal dumb
doom decides not to immediately kill
Eddie again there's no doubt that after
three near misses Roger and Jessica
should have at least been hit with some
incidental spray by now this is horrific
millions of kids watch this guy's
I mean seriously that guy turns back on
the thing we already didn't get all that
tense about in the brief in alley 30
seconds of taking too long to kill Eddie
after being ridiculously sprayed with a
dip doom still somehow was alive and
intact enough to keep screaming and
living homage or straight theft of The
Wizard of Oz yeah it doesn't matter I
thought you had to drive through the
back to the future to tunnel to get to
toontown but it's an ACME SPAC yard
apparently magic fire hydrants are all
over the place at the Acme factory to
wash away all the dip no one could
foresee existing when they were
installed and this is the route for the
safe that was dropped on a key I think
your lab boys a finite paints a perfect
match but almost entirely useless less
evidence since everybody in this Factory
could have used that rope and it doesn't
necessarily exonerate anyone approved
guilt that's what I call one seriously
disturbed - wait until you see heavy
metal that's wicked couldn't you just
say can't movie pretends to know the
origin story of Porky Pig saying that's
all folks but he was saying it well
before 1947
[Applause]
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out
and now the audio outtakes the couple
has found one another and at last the
family is together you didn't
[Music]
oh yeah I used to be a Salesman it's a
tough racket well whether you state with
the TV show or your political political
doesn't scare me Tommy how's the beeping
[Music]
Tommy it's gonna get worse before I
can't better this is all farmland as far
as the eye could see
oh man Peabody on all of this you had
this crazy idea about breeding pint